my mum was there my sister-in-law was
there
and they started to beat me and this was
a different kind of beating it was
almost as though they were determined to
kill me and all my life I'd been
threatened that we will bury you under
these floorboards and I really believed
they would and within no time they had
broken my jaw
they had
broken my arm and
I was in a lot of pain
[Music]
so my parents originate from the Punjab
in North India
they came over in the 1960s and I always
say that they packed very tightly their
cultural beliefs and unfortunately for
me that meant that girls were not wanted
or
desired but boys were so I was looked
upon as a bad entity almost like a witch
or a possessed child so everyone
wouldn't touch me or welcome me or hold
me because they felt I was carrying bad
spirits
were you the only girl in your household
so I'm the youngest of three I have two
older brothers and I'm the only girl
born in my immediate family but also the
only girl in my extended family with my
father being one of Seven Brothers my
normality was such that I was kept in my
room at the age of six
my room wasn't like a child a child's
bedroom whereby it's got nice
furnishings and soft toys it was very
bare brick walls the only time I was
allowed out of my room was to go to
school
or my mother would call me to cook
or I would be called to do another chore
like washing the plates or dishes or the
clothes because we didn't have washing
machines and I had no interaction with
my family I didn't make eye contact
girls are told to look down all the time
and I still have a bit of an issue
making eye contact with people
um primarily because we we get hit if we
make eye contact we get shouted out
so I was non-viable because I didn't
engage in conversation with my family I
had to not not speak I used to press my
ear against a very rough wooden door and
listening to TV programs and pretend I
was sitting with my family but my friend
at school would walk me to school and
sing me all the songs from top of the
pops and that's how I knew a lot of
music I amused myself with books I've
got a love of books still
I used to take as many books from school
as I could because they were my friends
I would name them and I really believed
in fairy tales and that I was Rapunzel
and then one day I would be saved from
my room
what was your relationship with your
parents like I was very scared of my
mother and father and a lot of people
don't understand that women play a big
role in my community as much as other
communities that are like mine and
cultures that light mine whereby the
person that would call me out of my room
would be my mother the person that was
watching a lot of my abuse was my mother
and she herself was very angry all the
time just by my existence
I wanted to please my father I would go
out of my way to do things to make my
father happy and by that I mean I would
cook food as quickly as I could and most
kids have a toy they remember from their
childhood but I remember he brought me
back a blue crate that had bottles in it
and I turned it upside down which meant
when I was a little six-year-old
seven-year-old I could reach everything
so much quicker in the kitchen and I
thought maybe that was an extension of
his love to me as well I mean you
mentioned that you were able to go to
school what was school like for you
so school should have been an escape and
it was to a certain point because of the
books and the teachers were quite
pleasant but I was the only person of
color in my school with my brother so
you would hear the word scrap and people
running and it was because I was being
piled upon and beaten or it was my
brother being beaten my hair was pulled
I was spat upon and every day was a bit
of a battle in a different way
I had literally a couple of friends
because nobody wanted to be my friend
because they too would be picked on but
the ones I had were very loyal and very
loving and I wasn't allowed at lunchbox
and my first experience of Cham sandwich
Jam sandwiches was because my friend
offered me one of hers knowing that I
wasn't getting any food at lunch times
and you know I remember making a little
Jam sandwich last for the whole of the
lunch time so I could be part of the
lunchtime Community sitting inside
instead of sitting on a bench waiting
so my father from the age of sort of
seven upwards would bring back
a group of his friends and I knew them
all and in my culture you don't say
names you say uncle or Auntie to anyone
that's older than you
and they would come and they would eat
and they would drink and my father owned
a lot of pubs so my father was the place
to go to because he had the alcohol
and you know he would come back from the
pub and my mother was the one who would
wake me and say go down she would go
back to bed and I would go and cook rice
and chapatis and chicken and some
vegetables and I would take them on a
tray then I would sit on the bottom of
our large wooden staircase waiting for
them to finish because my father didn't
like mess
and when I got to 14
um my mother woke me up
and instinctively I had this horrible
feeling
I remember taking the food in
and waiting and I remember thinking I
don't want to go and pick the dishes up
because they're exceptionally loud
they'd started to bring bottles outside
my father used to put the empty bottles
outside and there was bottles of Johnny
Walker all lined up and then when I did
get the call
um I went in with the big tray that we
had it was a big white tray probably
bigger than me and he grabbed my wrist
and the tray fell down
and he was the first person to throw me
onto the table and rape me
I didn't know what was happening I was
too young
I closed my eyes
but I I lived without
um the ability to see so I knew each
person's sound of who it was each
person's touch almost
and it was a very horrific attack by
seven or eight men
on me
and I um
was thrown from person to person I was
beaten I Was Bitten
and eventually I
must have passed out
and when I came to it was because my
mother
opened and closed the door
and woke me up
and I remember not having my bottom part
of my clothes on
and I was literally lying in a bath of
my own blood
and the first thing I thought about was
there's food everywhere on the walls on
the floor and I'm going to be in so much
trouble
I didn't actually give myself
any consideration because
I believed I wasn't worth anything
because that's what they had taught me
from birth to believe
you mentioned your mother so how did she
respond straight after this attack
well my mother was the one who woke me
up as I said she opened and closed the
door several times
and she was angry you know
um it's all about perception
I look back sometimes and I say
could she have done anything
um did she show any act of kindness
and I know that she was the one who gave
me a new set of pajamas was that an act
of kindness or was she just doing that I
don't know but
she could have at some point just come
to see me and straight my hair or give
me some comfort but she was just angry
and almost made me feel that it was my
fault that I had asked for it that it
was me that had instigated the whole
attack
I was so naive I didn't understand what
happened you know we don't have
conversations about periods or sex or
relationships in my culture or cultures
like it it's a taboo to even think about
it so I just knew it was wrong but I
didn't school back then didn't teach us
these things
um and all I knew was that it was wrong
and I didn't feel like me anymore
she allowed me to have a shower and I
was never allowed to shower my brothers
were
they used to make me have bucket baths
which meant you have a bucket and you
fill it up and then you use a a jug to
wash yourself
but on this instant she told me to have
a shower and again
I thought maybe she was being kind but
the shower really stung so where I'd
been bitten
where I had open wounds it really stung
and I kind of wished I had had the
bucket bath but after that I had just
asked her if I could go to sleep because
I was in so much Agony I was in a lot of
internal pain naturally
but the mental pain was almost that I
felt broken I just felt like that was it
that was um the end of me
and we're living in fear that something
might happen again
I used to
walk in with that tray with my legs
shaking from that day forward
so every Friday or Saturday when my
father would bring his friends I was
visibly shaking and scared because I was
sure they would try to do something
again and then not knowing it's torture
there's no other word for it but it was
always upon me to go and face them every
weekend and and give them this food
I turned 15 and I realized I was
pregnant and I told my mum that I was no
longer having periods and I Didn't Know
I Was Pregnant but she told me that I
had spoiled myself
my dad was called immediately he came
and they both
sent me to my room and they were
shouting at each other and before I knew
her I was in the car and I'd never been
in my father's car and I remember it as
a
blue humberceptor and I'm sat in the
back looking at the trees and the clouds
and wondering where I was going and they
took me somewhere in the West Midlands
to a clinic and I remember arriving in
the clinic and there were lots of women
I remember the whole procedure and this
was the clinic where I was going to have
an abortion the thing I always talk
about is the act of kindness from this
whole experience of this abortion
because it was the first time someone
had actually extended love to me
and it was in the form of a lady where
after the procedure they make everyone
sit on a grass Verge and I had my sort
of Clinic gown on
and she brought me a cup of tea
but it wasn't the tea that she handed me
with it wasn't the fact that she handed
me tea it was the fact she reached out
and touched my hair
and stroked me in a very maternal way
and I think it's it doesn't matter how
old you are we all crave love
and I realized at that point I really
was craving some love from another human
and I realized as well that maybe I
wasn't as bad because she didn't catch
anything by touching me and I was told
all my life and believed it that if
someone touched me they would catch this
evilness that I was containing
um and when we got home on the way home
my parents were
really upset saying what are we going to
do with her this is such a problem
nobody will marry her because to get an
arranged marriage you have to be a
virgin and I wasn't a virgin and I
blamed myself
so my father was really anxious for a
while after the abortion saying that
what will we do how are we going to do
this what we're going to do with owner
there was talks about me being sent to
India where they would either marry me
to an old man or kill me one of the
people that had raped me came forward he
was the person that bit me and he came
forward and said that he would take me
he wanted to have me in his house so
that he could have me as a sex slave and
his wife could have a servant but his
son was dating a White English girl in
in our culture that's not allowed but
it's very common and they were going to
have me marry the son so that the
community thought that the sun was good
it was a sham wedding it was
very brushed I was very young but my
father and he started to trade make a
trade for me
um they placed a silk scarf over my head
and I was forced to sit down and I have
a few pictures and I look at those
pictures and think what was going
through your head you look so scared
because I thought when I go to his house
will he call his friends will I be a
victim again of a group rape I didn't
know what to expect
and um my father and he argued about
gold and money
and eventually they came to an agreement
and everyone was happy and I kept
hearing this word happy happy happy and
I didn't know what happy was
I got to the age of 16 and I was married
and when I walked into the marital home
I first of all noticed how small it was
and they led me to a room and said this
is your room downstairs we sleep
upstairs but you don't and the room was
like a makeshift cupboard with a small
bed and an open space for clothes
they took all of my gold that I was
wearing for the wedding ceremony they
took all of my belongings and they
handed me old things and said I must get
a job
I didn't really ever speak to the person
I was married to he was living his life
he was happy
I don't think people understand that
cultures like mine the in-laws play a
very big part in
mental abuse and physical abuse and
often sexual abuse it's not spoken about
because there's a taboo is a stigma of
saying anything but the amount of mental
abuse a bride or a girl experiences from
her in-laws is actually it destroys that
person I was told that I would do all of
the cooking and there was no door so
that I could be accessible to my
father-in-law who would come in and rape
me and attack me and threaten me he had
a real craving for control and to scare
me which he did there was a thing in the
90s called The Bride burning which meant
there's a lot of brides being burnt in
the area I lived and what I mean by that
is they were giving their husbands baby
girls so the women from the community
and the mother-in-laws and the
father-in-laws would blame the bride and
they would pour petrol over the girl and
set from fire and the police would turn
up and disappear thinking it was the
suicide and they would say that they
didn't know what to do they didn't want
to get mixed up in it so
I was literally dodging my father-in-law
because on the weekends he would tie me
up with metal coat hangers around my
ankles and the metal would actually dig
into my skin
and he would strip me so I couldn't move
I would sit there and soil myself
because I couldn't use the bathroom
and I was really really scared I was
scared of everything I was
very skinny because I had an eating
disorder
every time I would plate some food at
the end of preparing a meal my
mother-in-law would throw it into the
Dustbin
and tell me
she would tell me to eat out of the bit
because she said it's not your fault
themselves
and you just don't deserve to eat like
one of them
and at first
I used to try and get
food out of the bin
because I was hungry
but then I just gave up
so
are you ready to uh to keep going cool
thank you
you mentioned that you had a job how did
it feel having that sense of
Independence finally I actually started
to discover me at work I started to
discover who I was I got this job and I
started to notice
a different culture and I quite liked to
take some control of my own life in the
workplace but I also wanted to do well
because I thought if I earn more money
for them they might leave me alone and I
did make some friends which were who
were very important in my journey I
guess
um in my second job that was selling
Kitchens on the phone which I absolutely
loved because it meant I was constantly
on the phone talking to people I met an
Indian girl who had a Nigerian boyfriend
and we connected because we were both
Indian but she would notice things and
she would say why are your ankles
bleeding you know why do you have
bruises and I felt I could trust her so
I started to tell her things and she
didn't judge she didn't judge or make me
feel stupid or silly she actually would
just listen and then one day she said
you know my parents weren't very
understanding but they are now because
I'm older why don't you go back to your
parents house if you're so scared and so
unhappy and I started to again dream
about things because I was a Daydreamer
I started to almost visualize this fairy
tale of walking into my parents home and
them holding me tightly and telling me
that they loved me and they were proud
of me because I think that's what every
person wants their parents to be like to
give them that love and so I went to
work one day and I never went back I got
onto a bus to my parents house and and I
was sat on the bus and no you know a
known unknowingly celebrating to myself
that I'm going back home I'm it's
something I'm familiar with you know
it's my home and I'll be able to see my
dog and I'll be able to speak to my mum
not even thinking that you never spoke
to your mum life was never that good at
home
what happened when you did arrive home
I wasn't scared for the first time I was
kind of excited to see my family I
hadn't seen them for four years
and my father opened the doors a little
bit surprised he was at home because it
was during the day it was mid-afternoon
and immediately pulled Me In by my
ponytail and dragged me in and I thought
I've just made the biggest mistake of my
life
he took me into the same room in which I
was raped
my brother was there my eldest brother
my mum was there my sister-in-law was
there
and they started to beat me and this was
a different kind of beating it was
almost as though they were determined to
kill me and all my life I'd been
threatened that we will bury you under
these floorboards and I really believed
they would I remember my dog barking in
the other room they'd shut her up in the
other room so she wasn't able to come
near me and I
desperately wanted out but I didn't know
how to get there
my father is an ex-professional wrestler
my brother's six foot tall and I was
this very
thin small 21 year old
and within no time they'd broken my jaw
they had
broken my arm and
I was in a lot of pain
I was literally bouncing off the walls
like a little Ragdoll and
I fell to the floor you'd never forget
what people say and how they say it and
they were telling me I was a
disappointment that they knew that this
would happen because I was a girl and
they didn't want that girl they should
have killed me from birth and what they
meant by that is when I was born a lot
of
girls were put into plastic bags and
suffocated and buried in the garden and
I know this because people would come to
my mom's house and give birth to a girl
and not report the birth so nobody knew
about the pregnancy so I was always told
I was very lucky to be alive and I was
really scared of dying
um my brother started to kick me and my
father started to stomp on me and they
displaced my hip and there was probably
no part of my skin that wasn't cut or
covered with bruises or blood
came to a time where my father held his
foot
on my throat
and I felt at that moment I left my body
and I remember looking at myself and
thinking
this is it this is this is it now for
you but I heard something that sounds
strange but it's what I believe and I
know what happened and something said to
me not yet it's not your time just yet
and I remember going back into the body
and feeling nothing I was a numb I knew
they were still kicking and punching and
and you know stamping on me but I wasn't
feeling anything all I was doing
was watching blood literally drip from
my head onto my nose and into the carpet
and they continued I remember feverishly
looking up towards my mum and my
sister-in-law maybe in a way to ask for
help
and I remember them standing with their
arms crossed and they were very very
angry
and before I knew it my other brother
walked in shouted not here
and they all just disappeared very
quickly and I remember passing out and
coming to and passing out
and the door opened and somebody said
they're going to take you to India ask
for help it's security and I thought
what a silly thing to say to me because
if I have my brother on one side and my
father on the other I'm not going to ask
for help and I thought to myself am I
ready to add I don't want to live
anymore but then this little voice was
saying no
I don't want to die
and I've tried to get myself up but I
couldn't I tried to I like almost like a
baby crawl and I couldn't so I started
to talk to myself and I said if you can
get to the door and you can reach the
handle you've only got to get to the
kitchen if you can get to the kitchen
you've only got to get to The Back
Garden if you can get to the Back Garden
you will be free I didn't even know what
free meant or where I would go but I
knew I had to get out of there
and um
it sounds very fictional I know and I
know I look literally like something out
of a horror movie but I started to move
and my body was stiff because I'd laid
in the same position for days and I was
dirty and smelly and like I said I was
covered in blood everywhere but I did I
started using this part of my arm
and I shuffled forward and I would fall
I would internally cry because I was too
scared to make a noise I knew I had a
very small window of opportunity before
this angry household would know that I'm
trying to escape
but I did and I got to the door
and then I got to the kitchen and when I
got to the Garden my father had the six
foot high wall and I thought I'm not
going to be able to do this
and I sat there
literally and thought I can't do it and
my dog came
and she was the loudest person she would
bark she would make so much noise the
neighbors would complain and I remember
touching her wet nose and and almost
begging her not to say anything
and I really believe sometimes in life
we've really come to a Crossroads where
we just need one person to say you've
got this in whatever form they come
and I believe in angels and I
felt she was this messenger or an angel
saying to me go because she looked up
and she looked back at me
and somehow I managed to get on top of
this fence and then I fell on the other
side and quite a loud way thinking they
might hear me but
I crawled literally crawled over to a
little Park opposite my house and I
passed out in the bushes and they never
found me and when I woke up it was early
hours of the morning I have no idea what
time it was but the birds were singing
and I managed somehow to get to a taxi
rank which wasn't too far away and when
I got there
I had no money
I could barely stand
and the person that came to me was this
white British man and he was so kind and
he said who's after you what's happened
and I said my parents trying to kill me
and he got me into the back of his taxi
covered me with a blanket and said where
am I taking to the hospital to the
police and I said no can you take me to
my friends please and he did he took me
to a place called Market Harborough
which is in leicestershire where my
friends lived
but nobody answered the door but he
didn't leave me he stayed with me and
eventually took me to the police station
and I remember collapsing in the police
station and I remember the policemen
saying what happened what happened
started to take photos
and um I told him it was an attempted
honor killing he almost looked
disappointed and uncomfortable and like
he didn't know what to do and he said
the best thing for you to do is to get
to a hospital and before I know it I was
on my own in a hospital lying on this
bed
nobody visited me nobody asked me who I
was the nurses would come and do their
observations and disappear without
looking at me as though I was there I
watched the people in each bed
and their families
and I knew he was coming at what time
but I also knew that nobody was coming
for me
have you had any communication with your
family since since you left my brother
came looking for me 15 years after I had
moved out because he had attacked his
partner at the time with a hammer and
the police had put him into some sort of
program whereby he didn't have to do
jail time if he put right what he had
ever done in his life and he said to
them openly that he had attacked me in
an honor killing attempt
and I was scared because I was still
scared of my brother and he asked for
forgiveness and I said I forgave you all
a long time ago but I just cannot forget
people and don't understand why I
forgiven them but I forgave them the
moment they did something wrong because
that's the kind of person I was
I don't speak to my parents now I have
been continuously threatened
and um
haunted by them whereby they have said
they will
behead me so I get 30 to 40 death
threats
every month not just from them but from
people I don't even know especially the
Middle East and the way they look at it
is if you leave an arranged marriage
they have to kill you to retain that
honor
and I understand the importance of
speaking out regardless of stigma and
shame because they will continue to do
these things over and over again so
whoever it is you're protecting
the first and only person you should be
protecting is yourself
I don't speak out out of hate for my
culture or to bring disrespect to
Indians or Sikhs or punjabis whoever you
may be it's not for that reason it's to
say that
as humans we should value life whether
it's born that child is born a girl or a
boy they are a precious life
[Music]
and he became very violent pushing me a
lot pushing me down the stairs pushing
me in the wall grabbing my hair and
pushing it into the passenger side if he
was driving and I didn't know I was in a
violent situation until things were very
serious and when I was pregnant with my
third child and I was seven and a half
eight months pregnant and he pushed me
down the stairs
all right
I fell
he left
and I remember not feeling my baby move
you looked young he did look young but
it was after the marriage that I knew
that he was twice my age so I was 15 he
was 30. I knew I knew he was going to
rape me and that's what happened and it
became like every single day